[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام انا طاهر بركه
احييكم وهذه العربيه 360 حيث الخبر من كل
زواياه ومن جميع جوانبه
[موسيقى]
لليوم الثاني اتهامات واستدعاء للتاريخ
بين بوتين وبايدن والصين تسعى لضوء حوار
في نهايه النفق
رغم بدء تفتيش وكاله الطاقه وتاكيد خبراء
ان طريقه ايران للسلاح النووي بعيد
اسرائيل تناقش خططها للضربه
السلطه الفلسطينيه تلجا لمجلس الامن طلبا
لحمايه دوليه بعد اقتحام نابلس والادانه
العربيه تتوالى
لدينا ايضا
اردوغان يسابق زمن لارضاء ثمانيه ملايين
بمناطق الزلزال وفي سوريا سباق اخر لملئ
مخازن المساعدات
اليوم كما الامس يستمر سجال التصريحات
والتصريحات المضاده بين الرئيسين الامريكي
والروسي بدا فلاديمير بوتين اولا بالتاكيد
على ان الحرب في اوكرانيا هي امتداد
للمعارك التي لا تزال مستمره على حدود
روسيا التاريخيه ليرد عليه بايدن خلال
الاجتماع مع مجموعه بوخارست في وارسو
بالتاكيد على استمرار الدعم لاوكرانيا حتى
تسترجع سيادتها وحريتها
من اطار العمليه العسكريه الخاصه نحن
اجتمعنا هنا اليوم لنحتفل وانا سمعت
القياده العسكريه اليوم بان المعركه لا
تزال مستمره على حدودنا التاريخيه ومن اجل
مواطنينا
ويقود هذه المعارك اولئك الابطال من بينهم
من يقفون الى جانبنا اليوم فهم يقاتلون
بشجاعه وببساله ونحن نعتز ونفتخر بهم
واليوم الدوله باكملها تدعمهم وفي هذا
الصدد ومن اجل حمايه مصالحنا وشعبنا
وثقافتنا واراضينا يعتبر شعبنا كله من
حماه الوطن
تحدثت مع رئيس زيلنسكي وناقشنا موضوع
الحريات والديمقراطيات في اوروبا والعالم
معا سنواصل تقديم الدعم لاوكرانيا حتى
تتمكن من استرجاع حريتها وسيادتها قدمنا
مساعده امنيه حاسمه لاوكرانيا ودعما ماليا
للمزيد من اللاجئين وضمننا حصول اوكرانيا
على الخدمات الاساسيه خلال العام المنصرم
بفضل دوركم الرياضي عززنا ايضا حلف النيتو
سوف ندافع عن كل شبر من اراضي حلف النيتو
وفي هذه اللحظه المهمه نتطلع لمناقشه
الخطوات اللاحقه التي سوف نتخذها لابقاء
حلفنا قويا ونتمكن من ردع اي عدوان مقبل
معنا من كيف مراسل العربيه حذيفه عادل من
وارسو موفد العربيه حسين قنيبر ومن موسكو
مراسل العربيه عبد الجواد الرشد اهلا بكم
جميعا في العربيه 360 ونريد ان نقف على
يعني ان نرصد معكم جميعا ردود الافعال
والاصداء على هذا التراشق بين الرئيسين
الروسي والامريكي وابدا في البدايه مع
مفدنا حسين قنيبر الى وارسو حسين
مساء الخير يا طاهر استدعاء التاريخ كما
سميته وانت تتسلم النشره من زميلتنا ميسون
حصل بالفعل خلال اليومين الماضيين امس
الرئيس الامريكي ذكر في القلعه الملكيه
المجاوره للقصر الرئاسي الذي يبدو خلفي في
الصوره تحدث بايدن عن وارسو المدمره وذكر
بافعال جيش الروسي خلال فتره الاتحاد
السوفيتي السابق واليوم كان لافتا جدا انه
بعد انتهاء الاجتماع الذي عقد بين الرئيس
الامريكي
وقاده الدول الاعضاء في مجموعه بوخارستا
تسعه جاء في التقييم الامريكي لهذا
الاجتماع ان الرئيس بعيدا عبر عن الالتزام
بل كرره الالتزام الصلب للولايات المتحده
بالبند الخامس من المعاهده المؤسسه اللي
حلف الناتو وهذه من المرات التي يتحدث
فيها الرئيس بايدن شخصيا عن هذا البندل
خامس من معاهده النيتو الولايات المتحده
ملتزمه بهذا البند هذا البند للتذكير
سريعا ينص على ان اي هجوم يستهدف دوله
عضوا في حلف الناتو فكانما استهدف الحلفاء
جميعا بمعنى ان الدوله التي تعتدي على
احدى دول الحلف فكانما اعتدت على دول
الحلف جميعا ايضا اكدت الولايات المتحده
خلال هذا الاجتماع على التزامها بالامن
عند جانبي الاطلسي وعبر القاده المشاركون
في هذا الاجتماع عن رغبتهم في تعزيز
الوحده فيما بينهم وتعزيز الدفاع المشترك
خلال قمه حلف الناتو التي ستنعقد فيه
فيلينوس بي ليتوانيا في الثاني عشر
والثالث عشر من حزيران يونيو المقبل كما
ان الدول المشاركه في هذا الاجتماع عبرت
عن الرغبه في تقديم الدعم الثابت
لاوكرانيا مع اشاره الى ان التباينات ضمن
مجموعه بوخارست تسعه تسجل تحديدا بين كل
من هنغاريا وبلغاريا من جهه وهاتان
الدولتان متحفظتان على الدعم العسكري
لاوكرانيا وبين الدول السبع الاخرى
المشاركه في هذا الاجتماع مع الرئيس بايدن
والذي شارك فيها ايضا الامين العام لحلف
هنا في القصر الرئاسي الذي يبدو خلفي في
العاصمه البولنديه تبقى معنا حسين لو
تكرمت عبد الجواد الرشد من موسكو واخر
ردود الافعال والاصدقاء على مختلف الاصعده
وشرائح الرسميه والشعبيه على هذا التراشق
الحاصل
مساء الخير يا طاهر لك والي الزملاء
الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين اليوم خلال
او عشيه عيد حماه الوطن وهو العيد الاول
للجيش ولكل من خدم في القوات الروسيه
يتحدث عن ان الشعب روسيا باكمله يدافع
اليوم عن اراضي روسيا الامه وان روسيا
وصلت الى ما عليه الان بوقوف جميع الشعب
مع الجيش الروسي وعلى ما يبدو انه يتحدث
عن العمليه العسكريه في الاراضي
الاوكرانيه طبعا الخارجيه الروسيه اليوم
كانت قد تحدثت ووصفات زياره بايدن لكيف
بانه طبعا عرض يعني عرض فاشل كما سمته
لمسرح خفيف وان موسكو قامت بمنح الضمانات
للقيام بهذه الزياره ترى طبعا في زياره
بايدن الى المنطقه والعديد من العواصم
الاوروبيه الشرقيه بانه يزيد من تصعيد
الموقف وزياده الاعمال العسكريه والدعم
اللوجستي والعسكري لنظام كيف كما سمته
الخارجيه لكن طبعا خرج اليوم وتحدث من
جديد على ان موسكو ستقف في مواجهه هذا
الدعم الكبير بكافه اسلحتك حتى لو وصل
الوضع لانه لكن منذ دقائق طاهر طبعا خرجه
السفير الروسي لدى المملكه المتحده وتحدث
بان موسكو لن تستخدم في الوقت الراهن
سلاحها النووي ولا تهدد احد باستخدام هذه
الصواريخ طاهر طبعا الموقف اليوم في روسيا
بشكل كبير عشيه عيد حماه الوطن يتحدث عن
ان الوقوف مع العمليه العسكريه خاصه قبل
يومين على تاريخ بدئها منذ سنه من الان
يعني معظم مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي اذا ما
تم النظر اليها بشكل كبير فمعظم ما نشر
فيها يتحدث عن الجيش وعن من خدم في الجيش
الاعلام الروسيه اليوم رفعت في العديد من
المناطق خاصه في العاصمه الروسيه موسكو
شاهدنا في مداخل الحدائق حتى وهذه طبعا
خطوه غير مسبوقه لم يسبق وتم رفع العلامه
الروسيه عندما داخل الحدائق وعلى سبيل
المثال حديقه غوركي في مركز العاصمه
الروسيه لذلك الاتجاه في البلاد اليوم هو
تصعيد عسكري يتزامن مع مرور سنه طاهر
ساعود اليك بعد قليل كل هذا التراشق
الامريكي الروسي يخص اوكرانيا بطبيعه
الحال والحرب دائره على اراضيها
ونرصد ردود الافعال وبالتالي اخر المواقف
الاوكرانيه الرسميه والشعبيه على مختلف
الاصعده مع معك حذيفه
مساء الخير يا طاهر لك ولي الزملاء كيف لم
تذهب بعيدا من ردود افعالها حين زار
الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن اكيد وكذلك بعد
خطابه للشعب الفولندي في وارسو هي في ذات
الاتجاه ذهبت رحب المسؤولين الاوكرانيين
في نطاق واسع يعني على مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي بخطاب بايدن وتاكيده على دعم
اكيد ميخائيل بدلالكم مستشار الرئيس
ان تاكيد الولايات المتحده على مواصله
الدعم كييف هو يعني ان العالم الحر يقف
خلف
الديمقراطيه وكيف ملتزمه بالتكامل
الاوروبي ويعني العلاقه مع الاتحاد
الاوروبي
والذهاب بعيدا كما قال عن كل ما هو روسي
كما وصفه وذلك على العالم ان يواصل عمليه
الدعم العسكري والاسلحه وخاصه الصواريخ
بعيده المدى والدبابات الوصول ذلك سريعا
الى كيف لاستعاده اراضيها وقال ايضا ان
كييف هي عازمه على كسر شوكه الاتحاد
الروسي واحلام ما سماها واحلام بوتين
بعوده الاتحاد السوفيتي كيف سوف تكون حائط
الصدا الذي تصطدم عليه احلام الرئيس بوتين
كما قال ايضا اندريه وهو رئيس ديوان
الرئاسه الاوكراني اكد على ان يعني دعم
العالم الحر للديمقراطيه للحريه يمتحن هنا
في اكييف وقال انه يعتقد ان كيف ستنضم الى
حلف الناتو حتى قبل ان تنضم الى الاتحاد
الاوروبي وهذا ما يؤكده وقوف جميع الدول
العالم الحر خلفها اكيد ودعم كيف عسكريا
واقتصاديا طبعا ايضا تعلم ان الذكرى
السنويه قريبه جدا اسمح لي ايضا ان اشير
الى المكالمه الهاتفيه التي اجراها الرئيس
فلاديميرا زيليسكي الرئيس الاوغندي وهي
الاولى في تاريخ العلاقات بين البلدين
والمراقبين ينظرون المراقبون ينظرون الى
المكالمه بانكيف دبلوماسيا تخرج من منطقه
الامان الدبلوماسيه وتذهب بعيدا لحجز
الدعم لمشروع القرار الذي تحلم بان تمرره
في الجمعيه العمليه الامم المتحده بصيغه
السلام الاوكرانيه وفي يعني في الاجتماع
القادم للجمعيه العامه للامم المتحده
جميعا
للان على وجوده معنا قبل ان نتابع تحياتي
لكم جميعا
وسط الازمه والتصريحات المتبادله يبدو ان
هناك مبادره او على الاقل محاوله تختمر
لوقف الحرب فموسكو اكد التطابق وجهات
النظر بينها وبكين الى حد كبير بشان
القضايا الدوليه ورحبت الخارجيه الروسيه
بمبادره الصين من اجل وقف النار في
اوكرانيا بل واعلنت عن اعتقادها بانها
ستلعب دورا مهما في حل الازمه واشارت
موسكو الى تقديرها لموقف بكين بشان قضيه
اوكرانيا ووصفته بالمتوازن
ليست الصين وحدها هي التي تطالب بنزع فتيل
الازمه فوزير الخارجيه المجاري دعا لوقف
اطلاق النار واجراء محادثات سلام لمنع
تصعيد الحرب وتحويلها الى صراع اوسع خاصه
بعد خطابات بايدن التي سلطت الضوء على
خطوره المواجهه على حد وصفه
معنى اذا من جديد من كياف حذيفه عادل ومن
موسكو عبد الجواد الرشد وابدا معك عبد
الجواد هذه المره
نريد ان نعرف يعني تفاصيل اكثر عن طبيعه
حقيقه الموقف الروسي من هذه المحاوله
الصينيه الى اي مدى يمكن ان يتماهل موقف
الروسي مع ما تطرحه الصين لانه لابد وان
يكون هناك ما لا تريده روسيا على الاقل
الان فيما تطرحه بكين
طاهر يعني الاعلان الرسمي حول المبادره
الصينيه بما يخص الازمه الاوكرانيه
والوصول الى حل يعجب موسكو نوعا ما هذا ما
تحدثت عنه اليوم ماريا الزخارف التي قالت
ان روسيا اليوم تدرس بشكل كبير هذا
المقترح الصيني حول هذا الموضوع لكن ايضا
تحدثت عن انه الان من الضروري يعني عدم
الاسراع او التسرع في الحكم على هذه
المبادره باعتبار ان الخطوات يعني لابد من
وجود قواعد اساسيه اليها للبدء بالعمل
بهذه المبادره لكنها على الجانب الاخر
طبعا كما يقال باللغه الروسيه كانت تضرب
باليد اليسرى بنظام كيف كما سمته وقالت
بانه اليوم غير قادر على المسير في هذه
المبادره باعتباره غير مستقل بقراراته
السياسيه ولا يلعب دور في الساحه الدوليه
بشكل مستقل فهو مرتبط بشكل واسع بالنظام
الغربي وبواشنطن
تحدثت زخرفه طبعا موسكو تامل في المبادره
الصينيه بشكل كبير هذه هي قراءه المحللين
السياسيين والعسكريين في البلاد باعتبارها
طبعا متوازنه نوعا ما طبعا لم يتم التصريح
بشكل كبير حول ما تتضمنوه هذه المبادره
بكل تفاصيلها لكن طبعا موسكو تحدثت بان
الجانب الصيني قام بعرض هذه المبادره عليه
ويتم دراستها في الوقت الحالي لذلك طبعا
هناك بصيص امل نوعا ما طبعا لدى عامه
الناس طاهر في الوصول الى حل بما يخص
المبادره الصينيه خاصه انها تاتي من شريك
استراتيجي كما تسميها موسكو لكن على ارض
الواقع هو شريك حليف طبعا لكن بين قوسين
كما يسميها البعض وعصيات الذكرى الاولى
لبدايه هذه الحرب ماذا عن الجانب
الاوكراني الان حذيفه عادل
نعم في الحقيقه يعني بخصوص هذه المبادره
الصينيه طبعا قالت كيف على لسان وزير
خارجيتها انها تسلمت النقاط الاساسيه او
بكين شاركت معها النقاط الاساسيه وهي سوف
تدرس هذه النقاط وترد على بكين ولكنها لم
تتسلم صيغه واضحه للرؤيه من قبل الصين
الرئيسكي علق على ذلك وقال يعني ما الذي
يمكن ان تاتي به المبادره الصينيه او اي
مبادره اخرى خلاف يعني لم تاتي به
المبادره الاوكرانيه والصيغه الاوكرانيه
للسلام كيف الان هي تحشد الدعم يعني هنالك
توجيه واضح للخارجيه وان يكون هذا الامر
اولويه ان تحسد الدعم من جميع الدول
الاعضاء في الجمعيه العموميه الجمعيه
العامه للامم المتحده قبل انعقاد الاجتماع
القادم للجمعيه لتمرير مشروع قرار صيغه
السلام الاوكرانيه والتي تحمل بنود واضحه
كيف طبعا تقول انه اولا يعني بخصوص اي
مبادره يمكن ان تاتي من اي جهه هي يمكن ان
تقبل بان ياتي الاخرين ويطلب منها ان
تتنازل عن شبرا واحدا من اراضيها اي ان اي
صيغه للسلام تطلب منك ان تتنازل عن
المناطق التي ضمها الاتحاد الروسي بالفعل
هذه لن تكون مقبوله على الاطلاق الصيغه
الاوكرانيه والتي تطالب بان تكون هنالك
ضمانات امنيه خاصه من الدول دائمه العضويه
في مجلس الامن وان تضمن لها توريد الاسلحه
في حاله حدوث اي عدوان من اي دوله على
الاراضي الاوكرانيه توريد الاسلحه بما في
ذلك الطائرات وبما في ذلك الاسلحه
الهجوميه في ذلك
مضادات
الطائرات
ومضادات الجويه وما الى ذلك هذه هي الصيغه
الاوكرانيه التي ترى فيها الحلوى للخروج
من هذه الازمه ولكن ابتداء هي تطالب بان
تنسحب كيئه موسكو من جميع الاراضي
الاوكرانيه بما في ذلك المناطق الاربعه
شكرا جزيلا لك حذيفه عادل لمراسل العربيه
من كييف شكرا لعبد الجواد الراشد المراسل
للعربيه من موسكو كذلك تح اليكما
لنلقي نظره اكثر قربا على الموقفين الصيني
والهندي من الحرب هذان الموقفان اللذان
تعتبرهما روسيا مهيمنين جدا على الساحه
العالميه مثلث العلاقه بين هذه الدول
تختلف قوته من ضلع لاخر فما موقف الدولتين
حيل روسيا بشكل عام في الازمه التي شارفت
على انهاء عامها الاول
نشرت تقريرا عن الموقف الصيني وقالت ان اي
انتكاسه لروسيا في اوكرانيا ستضعفها
سياسيا وعسكريا وبالتالي
ستضعف موقف الصين في مواجهه واشنطن
وحلفائها القلق الصينيه اتى بحسب الصحيفه
من ان زياده الدعم العسكري الغربي
لاوكرانيا سيؤثر على الموقف الروسي
ميدانيا ما يجعل بكين اكثر ميلا للضغط
باتجاه وقف اطلاق النار لمنع المزيد من
وبالطبع الحيلوله دون هزيمه روسيا لا ننسى
ان للصين مكاسب اقتصاديه مع روسيا تسعى
للحفاظ عليها فهي تتطلع لزياده وارداتها
من النفط والغاز والسلع الزراعيه الروسيه
اضافه لاقامه المزيد من شركات الطاقه
المشتركه في القطب الشمالي وزياده
الاستثمار في السكك الحديد والموانئ
الروسيه لكن ليس من الواضح حتى الان كيف
ستنعكس كل هذه الامور على سياسه ضبط النفس
التي تتبعها بكين نتحدث هنا عن امتناعها
حتى اللحظه عن دعم موسكو عسكريا نتذكر
تحذير وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه من ان
الصين تدرس دعم روسيا باسلحه مميته
كنا نراقب هذا عن كثب وحتى الان راينا
شركات صينيه وهناك لا فرق بين الشركات
الخاصه والدوله رايناهم يقدمون دعما
باسلحه غير مميته لروسيا لاستخدامها في
اوكرانيا القلق الان يعتمد على المعلومات
التي لدينا عن انهم يفكرون في تقديم اسلحه
قاتله
لكن الشكوك في سلوك الصين لا ياتي فقط من
واشنطن فوزيره الخارجيه الفرنسيه كاترين
كولونات قالت ان بلادها تراقب انشطه شركات
صينيه يحتمل ان تقدم مساعده لروسيا في
حربها في اوكرانيا كولونا اكدت ان فرنسا
تتحدث بكل دبلوماسيه ووضوح مع تكين وتامل
ان لا تمد يد العون لروسيا وان يكون لها
موقف واضح في جلسه مجلس الامن الدولي قبيل
ذكرى انطلاقه الحرب الرد الصيني جاء من
وزاره الخارجيه التي قالت ان الولايات
المتحده وليس الصين هي من توفر تدفقا لا
نهايه له للاسلحه
الولايات المتحده هي اكبر مورد للاسلحه
الى ساحه المعركه في اوكرانيا امس اعلنت
الولايات المتحده عن 500 مليون دولار
كمساعدات عسكريه لذلك يجعل البعض يتساءل
عما تنوي الولايات المتحده فعله من خلال
الادعاء الكاذب بان الصين تقدم اسلحه تدعي
الولايات المتحده انها تحافظ على السلام
لكنها في الواقع تكسب المال من الازمه
الان ننتقل الى الحليف الاخر لروسيا الهند
التي تتراس هذا العام قمه مجموعه العشرين
نقلت عن سته مسؤولين بارزين في الحكومه
الهنديه قولهم ان بلادهم لا تريد ان تناقش
مجموعه العشرين فرض مزيدا من العقوبات على
روسيا احد المسؤولين الذين تحدثت معهم
الوكاله قال ان الهند غير معنيه بمناقشه
او دعم اي عقوبات اضافيه وان العقوبات
القائمه حاليا على روسيا لها اثر سلبي على
العالم بحسب وصفه تحدثت نيودلهي عن ان
اجتماع وزراء ماليه ومحافظي البنوك
المركزيه لدول مجموعه العشرين سيبحث اثر
الحرب على الاقتصاد الكلي بشكل عام اليوم
اعادت الهند تاكيد اعاده تاكيد موقفها من
الحرب في اوكرانيا بالدعوه لسلوك طريق
الدبلوماسيه وحتى يومنا هذا تلتزم الهند
بالحياد في هذه الازمه واحجمت عن ادانه
روسيا وفي جانب اخر زادت مشترياتها من
النفط الروسي على مدار العام الماضي
[موسيقى]
هذه الحقبه ليست وقتا للحرب فالديمقراطيه
والحوار والدبلوماسيه هي سبل المضي قدما
في بدايه الملف قلنا قلنا علاقات مثلث
روسيا الهند الصين مختلفه بين دوله واخرى
والحلقه الاضعف هي علاقه الصين والهند
وزير الخارجيه الهندي سوبرمان جيشنكار قال
في مقابله تلفزيونيه ان علاقات بلاده جيده
مع القوى العالميه الكبرى بما في ذلك
روسيا ولكن ليس مع الصين جيشكارا اكد ان
العلاقه مع روسيا مستقره جدا رغم
الاضطرابات المتعلقه بحرب اوكرانيا بينما
علاقه نيودلهي مع بكيل على النقيض نظرا
لانتهاك الصين اتفاقيه اداره الحدود مع
الهند وبسبب نشرها قوات في المنطقه
الحدوديه المتنازه عليها
في العربيه 360 ايضا
اردوغان يميل لعدم تاجيل الانتخابات
لايمانه بان ثمن التقصير سيدفع سيدفع
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد استدعت الخارجيه
النمساويه سفيره ايران لدى فيانا بعد ان
حكم القضاء الايراني على مواطن النمساوي
بالسجن واوقف المواطن النمساوي في اكتوبر
من العام الماضي وحكم عليه بالسجن سبع
سنوات ونصف بتهمه التجسس مع سنتين من
المراقبه في حاله حسن السلوك
وفي المانيا دانا المستشار الالماني حكم
الاعدام الايراني ضد مواطن الماني مزدوج
الجنسيه مطالبا بالغاء القرار واستدعت
الخارجيه القائمه بالاعمال الايرانيه
للاحتجاج على الحكم كما قررت طرد اثنين من
موظفي السفاره الايرانيه ردا عليها
وفي تجاذبات الملف النووي الايراني وصل
مفتشون من الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه
الى طهران للتاكد من نسبه التخصيب في
منشات النوويه هناك الزياره تاتي بعد
تقرير لوكاله بلومبر قبل ايام اثار
المخاوف حول طموحات ايران النوويه بعد
العثور على جزيئات يورانيوم مخصبه لنسبه
وصلت الى
84% وهي نسبه قريبه من المستوى المطلوب
لانتاج اسلحه ذريه شددت الوكاله الامريكيه
على ان المفتشين عليهم تحديد ما اذا كانت
ايران انتجت هذه المواد عمدا او ما اذا
كانت تركيز ناتجا عن حادثا غير مقصود
اثناء تقسيم اليورينيوم في مئات من اجهزه
الطرد المركزي حينها وكاله الطاقه الذريه
لم تؤكد ولم تنفي تقرير بلومبرج وقالت
انها تجر مناقشات مع ايران بشان نتائج
انشطه التحقق الاخيره على ان تبلغ مجلس
محافظيه الوكاله الدوليه بذلك اذا لزم
الامر رد طهران على تقرير جاء على لسان
المتحدث باسم منظمه الطاقه الذريه
الايرانيه باهروس كاملوندي الذي قال ان
وجود جسيم او جسيمات مخصبه بنسبه تفوق 60%
لا يعني انتاج بتخصيب اكثر وان وجود هذه
الجزيئات في موقع التخصيب امر شائع اليوم
صرح رئيس منظمه الطاقه الذريه الايرانيه
محمد سلام بان المفتشين موجودون في طهران
ويقومون باجراء مفاوضات وعمليات تفتيش
لمنع ظهور حالات او حوادث غامضه جديده
[موسيقى]
للطاقه الذريه موجودون في طهران منذ امس
وهم يجرون محادثات وجولات تفتيشيه وتمحل
الغموض الذي صاحب تقارير احد المفتشين حول
نسب التخصيب ونحن نحافظ على علاقاتنا مع
الوكاله الدوليه في حدود الضمانات الاطراف
الرئيسيه في الاتفاق النووي لم تفي
بالتزاماتها والولايات المتحده لم تتعاون
بهذا الخصوص ولم تسمح ايضا للاخرين
بالتعاون لذلك لن نتسامح مع الضغوط
السياسيه واثاره المشكلات
[موسيقى]
لكن ما الذي تحتاجه ايران لانتاج قنبله
ذريه هذا بالطبع بعد العثور على جزيئات
يورانيوم مخصب بتركيز 84% كما قلنا نسبه
التخصيب المقرره لايران بحسب الاتفاق
النووي لعام 2015 تتراوح بين ثلاثه وخمسه
في المئه في يناير من عام 2021 وصلت ايران
الى نسبه 20% من التخصيب وهي نسبه كافيه
للاستخدامات الطبيه وايضا لاستعمالها
كوقود للغواصات ولحاملات الطائرات النسبه
وصلت الى 60% في ابريل من 2021 في ايران
مؤخرا ارتفعت النسبه الى
84% داخل منشات نوويه ايرانيه لكن عندما
ترتفع النسبه الى ما بين 85% وتسعين في
المئه هذه نسبه تتيح الاستخدام للاغراض
العسكريه لكن لن يقف الامر هنا فلا تزال
هناك رحله يقدرها الخبراء بين عام الى
عامين من اجل الحصول على سلاح نووي هذه
المرحله تشمل تصنيع راس حربي نووي ثم
تحسين نظام الصواريخ البلاستيه وتصميم
صاروخ قادر على حمل هذه الراس معنى هاتفيا
من القاهره رئيس هيئه الطاقه الذريه
المصريه الاسبق الدكتور علي اسلام اهلا بك
معنا دكتور مره جديده في العربيه 360 نريد
ان نستفسر منك لو سمحت في الجانب التقني
الذري ان صح التعبير هل ما قال به رئيس
منظمه الطاقه الذريه الايرانيه محمد
اسلامي صحيح باعتقادك من وجهه نظر تقنيه
بخصوص امكانيه وجود جسيم او جسيمات مخصبه
بنسبه فوق 60 في المئه ولكن هذا لا يعني
انتاج يورانيوم مخصب
بنسبه اكبر وان وجود هذه الجزيئات في موقع
الت امر شائع
مساء الخير اولا وشكرا للاستضافه انا بقول
هي فعلا موضوع محير لانه اساسا القدره على
التخصيب هي موجوده في طالما موجود اكيد
الطرد مركزي فاقدر على التخصيب لنسبه 60%
فهي قادره بالقطع على نسب اعلى
كثيرا فهو اللي يقدر على تصريب اليورانيوم
او اسرائيل اليورانيوم من نسبه
0.7% الى 20 الى 60
هو قادر تقنيا على انتاج وقود نووي
ممكن يستخدم في انتاج غير كلمه ولكن هي
المساله زي ما التقرير الممتاز اللي حضرتك
عرضته انه مهياش الموضوع فقط هو الامتلاك
الوقود النووي او
المراحل الاخرى يعني ما بعد التخصيب طيب
بس معلش خلينا بمرحله التخصيب لو تكرمت بس
نفهم انك اكثر اذا وجود هذه الجزيئات
المخصبه بهذه النسبه امر شائع ممكن ممكن
حدوثه بغض النظر عن مدى مصداقيه ذلك ولكن
تقنيا ممكن ان يكون هناك جزيئات بدون
حقيقيا ممكن ولكن انا زي ما شفت التقرير
بيقول الغموض في هذه المساله قد حل مع
الوكاله فيجب الانتظار بتقييم الوكاله
والتقريب اللي بتقدمه
لمجلس محافظ الوكاله المفروض يعقد فيها
يعني تكون هذه الجزيئات موجوده ويكون امر
شائع بدون وجود
نيه لانتاج جيرانيوم لتخصيب اكثر كيف
تقنيا ممكن يعني
تقنيا ممكن
الاجهزه يعني زي ما انا قرات في هذا
الموضوع انه ممكن يكون في اثناء
الاسراء يكون في في بعض الانابيب وصل
الاسراء الى اكثر القضيه انه هل هذا متعمد
ولا غير متعمد هذا
ينتظر من تقرير الوكاله الذريه للطاقه
الذريه
الفني اللي بيقول فعلا انا زي ما قلت انه
هو موجودين دلوقتي في او كانوا موجودين في
في ايران بيبحثوا الموضوع من ناحيه
التقنيه فننتظر التقدير
يعني نجدد التاكيد عليه معك دكتور انه على
المفتشين تحديد ما اذا كانت ايران انتجت
هذه المواد عمدا او انه كان عن حادث غير
مقصود هذا ما تؤكد عليه ولكن بخصوص الحادث
غير
هو يعني نقص في الامكانيات في الخبرات او
انه هذا ممكن ان يحصل في كل دول العالم
النوويه
لا مش قادره اجيب على هذا السؤال من ناحيه
ان التجربه دي فريده فينا معها يعني
[موسيقى]
الاجهزه اللي موجوده والتفاصيل الفنيه
الدقيقه
للتصميم بتاع هذه الاجهزه وانتقال
اليورانيوم من مكان لمكان هذا ممكن تقنيا
وارد انه يحدث
ولكن هو القضيه في انتاج القنبله هو
الاراده لانتاج الاراده نعم والمراحل
المقبله ايضا كما ذكرنا
وطبعا الامكانيات فالامكانيات لان الاسراء
وارد انه يحصل قريبا موجوده ولكن ما بعد
اليس كذلك يعني ليس فقط النسبه
الكميه الكميه التقنيه الانتاج نفسها او
نوعها ثم
الوسيله ايصال هذه الرؤوس الى
اهداف فهي طبعا موضوع يعني
كميه الكميه يعني ليس فقط نسبه التحصيل
الكميه وانا اعتقد طبقا لتقارير الوكاله
والتقارير الغربيه بيقول الكميه قريبه جدا
من
من من الكميه اللازمه
لتصنيع قنبله تشبه قنبله هيروشيما وليست
القنابل الحديثه جدا
يعني دكتور ضربه اسرائيليه مثلا او غير
اسرائيليه عسكريه بالمعنى العسكري بغض
النظر عن الموقف السياسي ولكن نقصد انه
تعامل عسكري مع الموضوع لن يكون خطيرا جدا
وثم هل له ان يعني يكبح جماح هكذا مشروع
ان يوقفه ان ينهيه
التعامل العسكري
يعني
لا اتمنى انه يحدث لانه اساسا التعامل
العسكري في اي مواد تحمل طبيعه خطيره زي
المواد الانشطاريه اللي هي
موجوده يعني ده ممكن قوي يتسبب في تلوث
البيئه على نطاق واسع وده لا اتمنى ان
يكون الا
تهديدات وتهديدات
متبادله في اطار انه
الموضوع يعني تفاوضي وحابه هذه اللحظه لم
يتم تاكيد اي شيء في هذا الخصوص فانا هذا
هذا الاتجاه خطير من اي جهه ان هو سواء من
الغرب او سواء من ايران الاقتصادم العسكري
يجب ان يكون مستبعد وهو اعتقد ان هو
الاطراف الموجوده
راغبه في عدم الوصول الى هذه النقطه ولكن
هي
يعني سياسه اكثر ومنها
يعني في الاتهامات المتبادله تهديد
ما بنقدرش
عن السياسه وحصاره الموضوع بالتعامل
العسكري عموما
التقني بينفذ سياسات
فهو طبعا انه انا بتكلم على
التقني الايراني او التقني في اي دوله
بينفذ السياسه العامه فهو حاليا هي موضوع
سياسي له
شكرا جزيلا لك رئيس هيئه الطاقه الذريه
المصريه لاسبك دكتور علي اسلامنا القاهره
تحياتي اليك
نتابع واياكم من الاخبار العاجله الوارده
عن موقف الخارجيه الامريكيه بخصوص نابلس
تقول الخارجيه الامريكيه قلقون من ارتفاع
منسوب التوتر بين في اسرائيل والضفه
الغربيه وتقول نقشه من تؤدي مداهمه
اسرائيل لنابلس لانتكاس في جهود التهدئه
الى الغرب من ايران تقف اسرائيل وهي تراقب
الوضع عن كثب القناه الثانيه عشره
الاسرائيليه افادت بان رئيس الوزراء
بنيامين نتنياهو عقد خمسه اجتماعات سريه
بخصوص ايران مؤخرا الاجتماعات جرت بعد
تقرير بلومبرج الذي تحدثنا عنه قبل قليل
وحضر الاجتماعات وزير الدفاع ورئيس اركان
الجيش الاسرائيلي ورئيس المصاد ومجلس
الامن القومي اضافه الى غيرهم من كبار
المسؤولين الامنيين الاسرائيليين القناه
الاسرائيليه اضافت انه تقرر خلال
الاجتماعات
مستوى الاستعداد العسكري الاسرائيلي
لمهاجمه المنشات النوويه الايرانيه بشكل
موسع وبخلاف الاجتماعات بعث نتنياهو رسائل
لوزير الخارجيه الامريكي ومستشار الامن
القومي الامريكي والرئيس الفرنسي شدد فيها
على انه اذا لم يتخذ العالم اجراءات ضد
ايران فستضطر اسرائيل الى التحرك منفرده
[موسيقى]
الخارجيه الامريكيه تقول معنيون بامن
اسرائيل لكننا قلقون بعد وقوع ضحايا
مدنيين في نابلس افاد ثلاثه مسؤولين
لرويتورز بان حكومه الرئيس التركي رجب طيب
اردوغان تميل لاجراء الانتخابات في يونيو
بعد ان تراجعت عن فكره تاجيلها اثر
الزلزال المدمر الذي ضرب تركيا وكشف
مسؤولون انه من المرجح للغايه الوصول الى
اتفاق لاجراء الانتخابات في الثامن عشر من
يونيو تجنبا لمواسم الاجازات مشيرين الى
ان اردوغان وحليفه القومي دوله بهشتي
سيلتقيان للتوصل لقرار نهائي لكن
المسؤولين انفسهم اشاروا الى ان التمسك
باجراء الانتخابات في موعدها لن يتيح
الفرصه للسلطات المعنيه لاتمام الترتيبات
اللوجستيه خاصه في المناطق المتضرره علما
بان المناطق التي ضربها الزلزال يقطنها
ثمانيه ملايين ناخب مسجل اي ما يعادل 14%
من الناخبين
وفي سوريا قالت الصحه العالميه انها
تستفيد من التوقف المؤقت للعقوبات بهدف
السماح بتوزيع المساعدات بسهوله اكبر
وافاد مدير قسم عمليات الطوارئ لمنطقه شرق
المتوسط بالمنظمه ان العمل جار بان العمل
جار مع الشركاء لضمان توفير المساعدات
والمعدات التي طال انتظارها
وفي سوريا ايضا حزن مؤجل ممرضون واطباء
سوريون تركوا امواتهم للاهتمام بالجرحى
بالجرحى الذين تدفقوا للمشافي عقب الزلزال
في مقابله خاصه بالعربيه تحدثت ممرضه في
احدى مشافي حارم في ادلب عن هول ما راته
وعن تحولها اما لبعض الاطفال في المشفى
من زاويه الى اخرى لمحاوله انقاذ من
ياتيهم بعضهم لفظ انفاسه الاخيره على
مداخل المشافي واخرون على ايديهم على وقت
يجيبوا لي الطفل فانا عم باخذه فبيقولوا
لي عايش عايش فبدي
بكون انفاسه الاخيره يعني ما بعرف لانه
انا فقدت رفيقتي هون راحت الضحايا كانت
ممرضه معنا جابوا لنا رئيس المشفى فنحن
عرفناه من استشهد الله يرحمه فتركناه
والتفتنا لغيره
الله يرحمه ففي عالم لسه لسه عايشه لسا
بالديانا فنحن رحنا لهناك الحزن المؤجل
رافق صرخه الخذلان فالاخيره باتت مالوفه
في سوريا وسقلتها حرب ممتده منذ 12 عاما
لتكمل عليها كارثه راح ضحيتها الالاف في
كل زاويه منها هناك من يبكي الفقد ويقول
لو كان هناك امكانيات او مساعدات لربما من
ابكيه ظل موجودا الارض خذلتنا
الحرب خزنتنا
كل الدنيا خذلتنا ما حدا اجا انقذ كانت
الدفاع المدني بالخط الاول
ما حدا اجانا من برا فخلاص وقفت وقف الصوت
الاصوات اللي نزلنا نسمعه تحت الانقاذ
ساعتين ثلاثه كان ما كان ضل اصوات
في العربيه 360 ايضا في نابلس اليوم وفي
نابلس غدا وفي نابلس كل يوم نبتوا الارض
يدافع عنها
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد قال وزير الخارجيه
الفلسطينيه رياض الملكي ان سلطه طلبت عقد
اجتماع طارق لمجلس الامن لادانه جرائم
اسرائيل وطلب توفير الحمايه الدوليه كانت
صحه الفلسطينيه اعلنت ارتفاع عدد قتل
الاقتحام الاسرائيلي لمدينه نابلس الى
عشره قتلى واكثر من مئه مصاب
العمليه العسكريه الاسرائيليه حدثت الساعه
العاشره صباحا كان هناك مقاتلان من عرين
الاسود يتحصنان في هذا البيت عندما
داهمتهم قوه اسرائيليه خاصه كانت تتذكر
بلباس رجال دين وكانت ايضا تحمل الاسلحه
سرعان ما حاصرت الشبان في هذه الغرفه
وقامت بقصف الغرفه بالصواريخ بعد ان رفض
المقاتلان تسليم انفسهم القوات
الاسرائيليه اشتباكات عنيفه دارت في محيط
هذا المنزل وهذا المكان في البلده القديمه
في مدينه
نابلس قام شبان فلسطيني برشق القوات
الاسرائيليه بالحجاره اضافه لانضمام عدد
ايضا اخر من المقاتلين من مدينه نابلس في
محاوله لصد الهجوم الاسرائيلي على هذه
المدينه نزلوا درجات جامع الكبير شيوخ
يعني كبار بالسن مشوا معهم سجاده في
الشفات على الحوش طلعوا منه الشباب رح
نتطلع على السريع رفع استجابه وطنوا
السلاح وفي كوزاره الصحه الفلسطينيه فان
حصيله هذا الهجوم الاسرائيلي على مدينه
نابلس وصلت الى عشره ضحايا من بينهم تجار
فلسطينيين كبار في العمر يتجاوز عمرهم
السبعين عاما كانوا يتواجدون هنا في هذا
المكان في متاجرهم واشغالهم اليوميه اضافه
الى الضحايا من الاطفال هذه الحصيله مرشحه
للارتفاع نظرا لوجود نحو 100 جريح بعضهم
اصابته خطره كان اي واحد يحاول انه يطول
يحاول يطول اي جريح او اي شهيد كانوا
مباشره
زي قناص يعني ما يضرب حواليه انه ينبهه
اصابات مباشره ردود فعل شعبيه فلسطينيه
غاضبه على هذا الهجوم الاسرائيلي الذي
يوصف بالاكثر دمويه منذ بدايه هذا العام
الفصائل الفلسطينيه في الضفه الغربيه
اعلنت الاضراب والحداد العام على ارواح
الضحايا في مهدده الفصائل وفي غزه بالرد
على هذا التصعيد الاسرائيلي الذي وصفته
بالخطير اما سياسيا فامين سر اللجنه
التنفيذيه لمنظمه تقرير حسين الشيخ وصف ما
جرى بالمجزره ودعا لتوفير حمايه دوليه
للفلسطينيين فيما قال رئيس الوزراء محمد
اشتيا ان اسرائيل تحاول تصدير ازماتها
السياسيه الداخليه الى الساحه الفلسطينيه
العشرات من المسلحين يشاركون في هذا
التشييع مع دعوات للرد على اسرائيل
بعمليات عسكريه مماثله من مدينه نابلس عبد
الحفيظ جعوان العربيه الاراضي الفلسطينيه
قال السفير السعودي لدى اليمن محمد الجابر
العربيه ان الوديعه السعوديه الجديده هي
جزء من حزمه لدعم الاقتصاد والتنميه في
اليمن اضافه الى تحقيق الاستقرار لسعر
الصرف في البلاد بحقيقه الوديعه هي جزء من
حزمه من الدعم التنموي والاقتصادي للاشقاء
في اليمن
هو مجموعه من الدعم تتكامل مع بعضها البعض
في خدمه الانسان اليمني وخدمه اقتصاد
اليمني ودعم مجلس القياده الرئاسه اليمني
ليقوم بدوره هو والحكومه اليمنيه في خدمه
الانسان اليمني ومواجهه التحديات الصعبه
التي حقيقه يعانون منها بشكل كبير جدا
فالحزمه مكونه من مليار دولار من المملكه
ومليار دولار من الامارات المملكه اودعت
بالامس مليار دولار في البنك المركزي
اليمني وهذا سيساعد في دعم الاقتصاد
استقرار سعر الصرف هذا سيساعد ايضا التجار
والرجال الاعمال في القدره على شراء
واستيراد وخاص المواد الغذائيه الاساسيه
[موسيقى]
في تصريح اليوم في العربيه 360 العلاقات
الاقتصاديه بين المانيا وروسيا تراجعت 20
عاما الى الوراء التصريح ولما يعرف باسم
اللجنه الشرقيه للاقتصاد الالماني التي
اوضحت كذلك ان الصادرات الالمانيه الى
روسيا خفضت العام الماضي بنسبه 45% وتقول
اللجنه ان الشركات الالمانيه تفعل اكثر
مما تتطلبه العقوبات الدوليه فهي اما
اوقفت مشروعاتها الجديده او انهت اعمالها
في روسيا بالكامل تحول مثير بالتاكيد فقبل
عام كانت العلاقات على افضل ما يكون كانت
مصانع العملاق الاقتصادي الاوروبي كانت
كلها تدور بمصادر الطاقه الروسيه
فيديو اليوم من سوريا في قاعات الاعراس في
ادلب لا وقت للاعراس لا داعي لمد افرع
الانوار فما اد خيوط الخيام او لا ولا
داعي لاقامه الولائم فاطعام المشردين او
لا من اصلا في ادلب سيقبل على اعراس بعد
خساره الاف الاحبه تحت الانقاض العرس
بالنسبه لهؤلاء الان العرس ان يناموا
ليلهم بامان
[موسيقى]
سوره اليوم من نابلس لا تراني بسبب دخان
قنابلك
ركز جيدا انا هنا في منتصف الصوره انا هنا
بكل الالوان سقط عشره مثل بنيرانك لكننا
لا ننتهي ولن ننتهي في كل مره ستاتي
ستراني طالما بقيت الارض سنبقى ان غبت انا
ان غبت انا سيظهر غيري وغيري سيظهر غيره
فانا نابلسي انا فلسطيني
شكرا لمتابعتكم العربيه 360 اخبار سعاده
تنقطع صهيب شراير معه الان برنامج اخبار
الساعه ولديه صهيب مساء الخير مساء الخير
طاهر سيكون لدينا المزيد مما انتهيتم اليه
هذه العمليه الاسرائيليه من اقتحام نابلس
وسقوط عشره قتله فلسطينيين سيكون ضيفنا
مندوب فلسطين في الامم المتحده رياض منصور
عظيم نتابعك تفضل
[موسيقى]